après 11 ans d'existence chambre et
trace sa route sans peindre son temps
installé en d1 depuis 2016 le club fait
ses débuts en europe cette saison un
changement de dimension qui rime avec un
nom celui d'alexandra lacrabère
à 34 ans chambre est le dernier défi
pour cette joueuse qui les a tous relevé
championne de france d'europe du monde
et olympique
elle continue de travailler sans relâche
son explosivité c'est hyper important
d'autant plus quand on arrive en fin de
carrière c
plus important qu'une séance de balle
pour maintenir le corps en forme pour
pour supporter les chocs donc
j'apprécie plus enfin la jeunesse
fin de carrière on dirait pas parce
qu'elle leur fait pour vous lancer le
fait bien en plus une sacrée athlète une
belle athlète qui adore les tra tous qui
a exposé éviter notamment tout ce qui
est répétition de sow qui a bien chargé
donc c'est vraiment charmant un plaisir
de beausoleil qu'alex
une fin de carrière qui n'est pas pour
tout de suite
d'abord il ya le derby régional qu'il
faut remporter ce dimanche face à son
ancien club de fleury et puis la
transmission le partage d'expériences
notamment à son poste lacrabère est une
arrière droite indéboulonnable et sert
de modèle à la jeune jeanne est la blogo
c'est pas du tout normal c'est une
coéquipière en 7 beaucoup sur le post
quand elle est sur le terrain je suis
sur le banc ya un temps mort ben je vais
venir et c'est aussi bien avoir un
regard extérieur vue parce que qu'on est
sur le terrain on a du mal à voir les
choses donc c'est vrai que l'entraîneur
il est plutôt sur la tactique
du groupe donc avoir une joueuse comme
ça à son poste aussi c'est assez
intéressant alexandra lacrabère s'est
engagé jusqu'en 2023 avec son dernier
club et à l'heure du bilan aucun regret
sur sa carrière
je suis fier d'eux
de ce que j'ai fait et
j'aurais signé de suite si j'avais su ce
qui allait se passer jouer à l'étranger
aussi ça m'a permis de grandir d'élargir
la vision de
surtout sur la vie sur sur le handball
donc voilà je suis plutôt fier et
et j'espère que beaucoup de gens peuvent
re
peut faire comme moi vivre leur passion
et
c'est extraordinaire
quant à la suite la bns passe ses
diplômes pour être diététicienne et pour
continuer à évoluer dans ce milieu
professionnel